okay
good morning everybody and welcome to
the meeting of mid-suffolk development
control b committee
please ensure you maintain social
distancing from all other persons whilst
in the chamber and the communal areas
please make sure that you wear a face
covering at all times unless you're
sitting down or exempt for doing so
and that you use the hand sanitizer
wipes provided
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations while
others are speaking if you are attending
the meeting to speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave
please ensure that you switch mobile
phones onto silent or switched off
we will be using e-voting for this
meeting on the modern.gov so please make
sure members that you are logged in and
ready to use
fire safety arrangements
if you hear the alarm leave the building
immediately via the fire exit and make
your way to the assembly point
ipswich town football ground
follow the signs directing you to the
fire exits each end of the floor
do not enter the atrium which is the
ground floor area and walkways
if you're the atrium at the time of the
alarm follow the signs to the nearest
fire exit
use the stairs and not the lift do not
enter the building until you are told it
is safe to do so
the council members of the public and
press may record film photograph or
broadcast across this meeting when the
public and press are not lawfully
excluded so we have the introductions
today we have john pateman g the area
planning manager
the legal advisor in dupre
morning
and the case officers today jasmine wild
hello
and governance officer alicia norman
and we have mandy who's driving our
machinery today
and uh the ward members our councillor
austin davis sitting at the back
and also councillor harry richardson
sitting at the back there and then
obviously the members of the committee
sitting either side
so can i have apologies for absence and
substitutions please do we have any
apologies
none received here thank you any
declarations of pecuniary and
non-pecuniary interest by members
no it doesn't look like it thank you
declarations of lobbying any
declarations of lobbying
no
and any declarations of personal site
visits
neither that thank you
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting held on the 23rd of march are
there any points regarding the accuracy
of the minutes please
no
may i have a proposal in the second of
those minutes councillor carsten
and the second if i may
councillor thank you
so may we go to a
an electronic vote i should say
thank you chair members that vote should
now be in progress
council of war boys are you having any
issues
with your mug
have you voted
do you want to take it further
can we take it verbally council or have
you voted
about it got it
thank you chair that is seven votes four
and one abstentions that is carried
thank you very much
do we have any
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme
none received here thank you
the schedule of planning applications is
one and one we will do thank you
so
we now move on to that first application
and i'll now invite jasmine wired to
introduce the application to the
committee
which is dc2104549
land to the south of heathrow thurston
thank you very much
thank you chair and good morning members
i'm presenting case dc 2104 549 today
which relates to the site land of the
south side of heath road thursday
the application is for the erection of
54 affordable extra care units
comprising of 40 apartments and 14
bungalows with communal gardens
landscaping and car parking
as per the table papers the local lead
flood authority have withdrawn their
holding objection and recommended
and have now recommended conditions and
suffolk county council highways have
also recommended a condition to secure
bus stop improvements
members are reminded that this
presentation accompanies the main
committee report and in no way seeks to
replicate the detail within that report
the committee report contains a range of
illustrative material and detailed
assessment to such an extent that this
presentation is kept succinct
the site falls within the thurston
neighbourhood plan area the
neighbourhood plan holds full weight in
the determination of this application
thurston parish council support the
principle of the development but
continue to raise concerns relating to
the ev charging points on site as
explained in the report and
notwithstanding the submitted
information it is proposed a condition
is included on any permission
which requires additional ev charging
points to be incorporated
thurston is a key service centre as per
the core strategy to this end thurston
is considered a reasonably sustainable
location in the rural context and is the
next sequentially preferable location
after towns where cs1 seeks to focus
growth
so in the uh geographic context this is
thurston um as you can see it's north of
the a14 south of the a143 and east of
boston edmonds
here we have the services and facilities
within thurston with the site shown
by that red sort of outlined area
with housing surrounding the site along
the north and eastern boundaries
here is the site location plan which
shows the site's boundaries uh to the
north is heath road and east is
malting's green and as you can see it's
surrounded by dwellings
as you can see it's an edge of
settlement location
here is an aerial view with the block
plan superimposed on it as you can see
the site sits within the wider part of
an agricultural field which is within
the ownership of a local charity
thurston's neighbourhood plan shows the
most up-to-date settlement boundary as
you can see the site abuts the existing
boundary to the east and to the north
the settlement boundary for thurston
that exists under the local plan is
shown by the brown line there
as per the previous slide thurston's
neighborhood plan reinforces this
boundary
the site itself is relatively
unconstrained with no protected trees or
listed buildings immediately immediately
nearby
however one constraint is that there are
pockets of the site which are at a low
risk of pluvial flooding
suffolk county council floods and water
have however assessed the application
and raised no objection from the
perspective of pluvial flood risk
the proposed layout plan shows one block
of apartments which is spread across two
stories and six blocks of
bungalows as well
parking is located to the periphery with
the access on teeth road located north
east
and landscaping is weaved throughout
to show you the proposed landscaping
there are kind of three distinct aspects
of it so you've got soft general
landscaping which is located along the
northern eastern and southern boundaries
you've then got the courtyard gardens
which are in that slightly darker green
uh which weave through the center of the
scheme with a small area also located to
the south
you've then got private amenity patio
areas which provided for bungalows and
ground floor apartments and balconies to
the first floor
zooming in on the courtyard gardens
you've got a range of courtyard spaces
which are included connected by pathways
with seating areas and shade scattered
throughout
on the the right hand side
of the screen is the apartment block and
one of the floors of the apartment block
with the terrace of bungalows shown on
the left
all units are self-contained spaces with
bedroom bathroom lounge and living areas
and within the main apartment building
there is a bistro cafe sun lounge
activity space staff offices and a staff
room
health suite scooter store and laundry
room
as you can see from the elevations the
buildings are of a modern appearance
with areas of articulation and detailing
creating interest and reducing one
uniform mass within the street scene and
on this corner of heath road
here we have some cgi's of the buildings
from different angles and i'll quickly
take you through these slides but they
should give you a flavor of how it would
appear within the street scene
so this first one looks along the
frontage from heath road
looking north west through the site we
then have the terraced bungalows
again looking north west this is in the
corner of the apartment block showing
structured landscaping with pathways
which aids permeability and legibility
around the site
finally looking north east through the
edge of the site you can see there's a
heavily landscaped area along the
western boundary
again with structured landscaping and
seating areas
the proposal is supported by specific
neighborhood plan policy as shown on the
screens that's policy three
members have previously emphasized the
importance of development that caters
for the aging population and those with
a range of specialist care needs which
this proposal
supports
again the spatial strategy within the
neighborhood plan as per policy one does
permit these types of schemes outside of
the settlement boundary
so in conclusion um the recommendations
to grant conditional planning
permissions subject to section 106
agreement if members are minded to
approve as per the officer's
recommendation it should be noted that
in addition to the recommendation made
within the committee report and tabled
paper
in order to secure the 100 affordable
housing in perpetuity the recommendation
will also need to be subject to a
section 106 agreement as on the screen
thank you for listening
and thank you can you just confirm um my
initial possibly um regarding the
condition for a bus stop was that in the
table papers i'm sorry
uh yes yes yes yes
that's important for us to make sure
that's there thank you
right members do you have questions for
the officer please
ansel norris thank you
oh yes right
uh
on page 37
at the top of the page
the first the sentence there we also
recommend a wildlife friendly lighting
strategy is implemented for this
uh sorry okay
up the top of page 37 the sentence that
reads we also recommend that a wildlife
friendly lighting strategy is
implemented for this application
i don't see this mentioned as such
specifically
in the conditions proposed on page 76
although it does mention
ecological mitigation
so would the wildlife friendly lighting
strategy be included within that that's
one question
my second question is
on page 52
paragraph 3.2.15
when i can find it
it does mention
disabled parking spaces
and it also mentions secure covered
uh cycle parking further down whether i
can see the secure cover
cycle parking in the conditions
on page 76 but i don't see any mention
about the disabled parking spaces
thank you
so taking your first question and so the
lighting strategy would be included as
part of the ecological mitigation
measures and as it specifically
specifically relates to um
obviously wildlife sensitive lighting
and in terms of the disabled parking i
don't believe i can see that it's noted
down but it's it's certainly something
that we intend to put on there so we'll
kind of add it on to onto that list of
conditions
thank you
of war boys and then councillor custom
thank you
thank you chair
um
two to have got two questions uh
one it was on page 33
that there's
it mentions about um
uh wheelchair accessibility
uh
the the standard the m4 standard
is not specifically designed for people
in wheelchairs
i
haven't visited um
establishments of care facilities i mean
this is one of the issues that's been
raised with me by residents is not only
the accessibility by wheelchairs but
also their storage and if they've got
battery
assists on them the safe charging of
these batteries as well which has become
an issue in care homes
as well um
[Music]
the second question is i'm not too
certain it's a planning concern you
might have to clarify with me
it on on a
on the sort of unified development of
this
nature is it possible to put in some
sort of strategy for energy use such as
the installation of photovoltaic cells
and the sort of strategy for the
energy efficiency of the buildings and
that is mentioned in the neighborhood
plan
where they they're talking about um
design but also
i've forgotten where i've put it now
a response to the climate change
basically they want energy efficient
buildings
okay so that's very two very good points
i actually brought up at the briefing so
i'm hoping the officer will be able to
give us the answers okay
yes so um taking your first point in
terms of the wheelchair accessibility it
has been confirmed by the applicants
that the scheme is to be designed in
line with part m
and the wheelchair design guide and so
there will be full access across the
scheme to wheelchair users
units are based on individual care plans
and the requirements of the residence
so the plans are designed to allow for
adaptations uh such as hoists across the
scheme
and all of the apartments and bungalows
will be fitted with housing 21's motion
spot shower room specification which is
fully adaptable and suitable for
wheelchair users as well
um in terms of the storage um of
wheelchairs and
the battery storage as well that you
mentioned
probably best to defer that um that
question to the applicants
um in terms of the energy usage
obviously there are a suite of
sustainability measures that are
included within and detailed within the
committee report um
last year in terms of why solar panels
specifically haven't been proposed and
we've got some some wording from the
applicant which is last year housing 21
conducted a review of the impact of
environmental and sustainability targets
on their new build development schemes
and how they'll achieve low energy usage
and reduce carbon emissions through
their designs and specification
this review resulted in new
specification in order to reduce the
carbon emissions which is reflected in
the proposed scheme which takes a fabric
first approach um with u-values well
below building regulation requirements
uh with a high degree of airtightness
with non-fossil fuel heating and hot
water systems being used
and all all of their schemes are gas
free as well
thank you
thank you madam chairman
in this scheme is there any
um specialist provision for ambulance
parking
i don't believe there's specialist
parking as in designated bays um you
might want to ask the applicants app but
in terms of the overall parking
provisions and whatnot obviously there
is access and um
yeah it would be able to accommodate
ambulances and
emergency vehicles if needed
thank you very much
right
so thank you i will now invite the
parish council representative julian
west to speak and you have three minutes
julian um mr west
so if you
just press the button then you should be
able
uh good morning ladies and gentlemen
overall the parish council is pleased to
be able to support this application on
the grounds that it will bring a much
needed facility to the parish of
thurston and mid-suffolk in general the
parish council feels that this
development fits in with the thurston
ndp with reference to policy one d
spatial strategy development proposals
to meet specialist housing and care
needs on site that are outside the
settlement boundary will be permitted
where it can be demonstrated that no
available and deliverable site exists
within the settlement boundary
and policy three meeting specialist care
needs in order to address the care needs
of older people in thurston the
provision of specialist care facilities
class c2 is supported
this includes the provision of
residential care home
the parish council is aware that this
site lays adjacent to the built-up
settlement boundary as defined in the
first and ndp which
is of the view that it represents a
sustainable site for development as per
proposals being discussed and as such
should be considered as being in general
conformity to thurston's development
plan
the parish council also considers the
benefits of this proposal are material
considerations and will include the
provision of a much needed facility
which will assist with pacific housing
for older people provide contribution to
the local economy and the local
environment
however the parish council is concerned
that the limited proposals being offered
in terms of assisting with measures to
reduce contributions to climate change
and would like to see further measures
conditioned at this stage
it is noted that the applicant in direct
communication with the parish council
has stated that they will ensure the
installation of ev charging points is
future proofed to allow easy expense
expansion of the number of charging
points
if and when future demand increases
currently there will be two electric
vehicle charging points installed within
the communal parking areas the scheme
along with infrastructure part of the
development
to facilitate future such installations
the provision is this provision is felt
to be insufficient for future needs
considering the sale of
fossil fuel cars and vans will be
prohibited in the uk from 2030
the parish council like to see further
ev facilities installed and notes the ev
charging guidance within the scc parking
standards revised 2019 that residential
institution should have 15
of all parking spaces to be fitted with
a charging system with an additional 15
of parking spaces with the
infrastructure in place for future
connectivity
the council would further like to ensure
that there is sufficient secure covered
cycle storage for not only residents but
also employees
cycling is an option around thurston as
our roadways are safe enough for all
levels of the population and
infrastructure plans are underway to
ensure there are general genuine
alternatives to the use of the car
the parish council agrees with the
premise that the employee cycle storage
should be a local lockable facility away
from public access to ensure the
opportunity to maximize the uptake in
cycling among staff is achieved
in conclusion the pc would like would
recommend conditions related to the
provision of ev charging points and
associated infrastructure along with
adequate cycle book parking provisions
the pc would also like to see much
needed medical facilities available
one one
line to the community that are mentioned
but not promised by housing 21 in their
original presentation
thank you
i think just to confirm some of the
points there i think
well yes i was just going to say i think
the planning officer covered the
charging points that there will be an
increase and john you wanted to make
some sort of comment please can i just
make a comment on both of those points
the ev charging and the cycle
so if members turn to page
97 of their papers in our recommendation
we say
refer to the highway conditions and all
of these conditions would be recommended
um
ultimately
on page 97
you have the
secure coverall site covered cycle
storage for both visitors and employees
uh to be agreed that's a recommendation
from the highways authorities can i just
stop you a minute we're on page 76 i
think are these in recommendations are
you talking about uh so i was looking at
the recommendations the consultation
response i've got it has page 97. all
right okay it's just
the response okay right carry on sorry
so our recommendation says see highways
yeah exactly and the highways is here on
page 97 which lists quite a number of
conditions and the
third
paragraph down is the condition on cycle
storage
so that is recommended to you
if i may
just go back up to page 96
i have just realized on the ev charging
infrastructure point the highways
authority have recommended that the
details of the electric charging points
need to be agreed by the local planning
authority
in our recommendation we've put a
condition for that to be agreed
however
the highways say prior to slab level uh
our condition in the recommendation says
prior to occupation
so there's a conflict between the two
so at this point may i
recommend that we go to the highways
which is the earlier point which is
prior to as well as
before slab level uh that's a correction
from us and i do apologize
yes i do see i think that's very clear
um in fact i have that start as required
by suffolk highways and i've put link
which is obviously everything we've got
there because sometimes the conditions
you've got to be a bit brief you can't
sort of write chapter and verse so sorry
i could see people were looking where
they were looking for so i think that
might answer any questions that people
might have for the um chairman so do you
have any um questions for
um
mr west
yes councillor malhon
thank you chair um
yes um
you mentioned that the the site this
site for the development is outside the
settlement boundary and but it would be
compliant with your neighborhood plan
because
um
your neighborhood plan says you could
have sites outside but only if there's
nothing within the development
boundary that's
that's suitable so can you confirm that
there is no other site within within
your
development boundary that is suitable
yes i can confirm that there is no other
site suitable for this sort of
application
i'm sure that was questioned right at
the beginning councillor it's a it's a
first point i would have thought
any other questions for the parish
council who gave a very fulsome
okay no thank you very much
um
and we now invite mark slater who is the
agent to speak and you too have three
minutes please thank you
so good morning members uh thank you for
giving me the opportunity to speak today
in favor of the planning application so
i'm mark slater work for west body
arcadia the architects for the scheme
i'm attending this meet with peter smith
from housing 21 who are the applicants
um firstly i think i'd like to make it
clear that we went through a formal um
pre-application process uh with the
planning team at baylor mid suffolk um
because that's just not noted on the
report
we also fully engage with members of the
local community
including first and parish council
and members of the public who are 70 in
favor of the site being developed for
the extra care
we've had regular discussions with
officers since
our application was submitted as well
so um just to explain a bit about the
scheme it's an extra care scheme for
older people and extra care offers an
alternative to institutional care homes
providing care ready housing choice and
crucially willing that enable local
people to live safe happy and
independent lives at the same time as
reducing the burden on local nhs
services
extra care offers individual
self-contained apartments and bungalows
for residents as well as the communal
facilities described earlier there are
care staff on site 24 7
and there is much research demonstrating
the very great benefits that extra care
living brings
um housing 21 is a not-for-profit
housing association its core goal is to
cater for older people of modest means
this scheme in first will be 100
affordable providing housing to the
local communities most vulnerable as
well as freeing up large family homes in
the area
the proposal is fully supported by the
thurston neighborhood plan um and has
already stated although it's outside the
development
settlement boundary um there is a
exception that allows um this type of
specialist accommodation to be located
outside
so the the design has been carefully um
developed to sit well within the context
of the local area and use a landscape
led approach so designed around
courtyard gardens of different character
and offers biodiversity net gains
through wildlife gardens hedgerows
wildlife grassland and
bird and bat boxes
it's highly sustainable and low carbon
and so there's no on-site fossil fuel
systems proposed and has high levels of
insulation very airtight construction
and then our renewable um source of
energy's air source heat pumps which can
buy mechanical ventilation provide the
heating and hot water for the scheme
um there is disabled parking although
not explicitly labeled on the plans or a
disabled parking show on the site plan
itself
um as well as a ambulance space for for
an ambulance to pull in although again
it doesn't have a dedicated space itself
um it's been designed specifically with
all the people in mind so it's been
designed to later thinking and dementia
design warehousing 21 of market leaders
has also used happy and wheelchair
design guidance to cater for both
physical and cognitive impairments
there is a buggy store on the ground
floor to um for storage of wheelchairs
um particularly electrical uh ones where
there's charging points there and
there's also cycle parking within that
store as well for staff
um so in in summary there are many
benefits to the scheme it's 100
affordable and provides housing and
support for local people in terms of
health and well-being but there are many
benefits beyond the building itself
including relieving pressure on publicly
funded care
yeah reduction in social isolation job
creation and release of unoccupied homes
and prevention of unplanned hospital
visits
thank you very much
thank you very much now members do you
have questions at all
councilman
yeah thank you chair um just a quick
question on heating you mentioned uh air
source heat pumps
is is each individual individual unit
getting their own sort of heating system
or is there a kind of a central one that
dispenses to each unit
uh there'd generally be a central one
within these schemes um is in the
apartment block with the bungalows we
might go to individual within the
individual
bungalows because it just makes sense
for distribution and heat loss and
things like that
council councillor stringer yep thank
you chair uh
mentioned in the
papers and in the presentation
that you take a fabric first approach
given the review you had about
sustainability and energy use last last
year in your report so
what fabric are we talking about
yeah
so that's in terms of walls roofs
windows yeah
so
um well in terms of we're well above the
building i couldn't quote you the evos
but on average it's a 50 improvement on
it no that wasn't the question question
what is the fabric
oh we haven't in terms of the
construction
i mean we haven't done the detailed
construction packages yet but um
generally be looking at a sort of
traditional masonry construction i think
on this type of development that frankly
is the most inefficient building method
for air tightness
so
this isn't a fabric first approach this
is a fabric last approach sure that's
not that's not that's not that's not the
first approach
sorry
so well in terms of the fabric you can
make um any you can make
traditional construction airtime through
through various methods
excuse me cancer can i just ask a
question of the planner and the legal is
this um a planning or a building rig
question i understand your interest in
your knowledge on these things i'm just
trying to clear it
with the planning officer and the legal
officer just if that's
relevant i know it's relevant but if
it's
critical to a decision if you see what i
mean
then you may continue obviously yeah but
there's a couple of things here uh
there is obviously building regulations
that have a particular standard in terms
of construction but in planning terms uh
i believe the member is trying to
ascertain the level of environmental
harm uh in respect to the proposal
uh and on that basis these questions are
relevant
in order for him to make that judgment
in the debate and how much weight he
wishes to put to that um i would say
though
forgive me counsellor
you're entering a bit of debate with
with the uh the
person here
um thank you for the clarity on that and
i hope you don't mind me asking for
clarity too because it helps us you had
a further question
thank you
i just wanted that reassurance which i
which i feel i haven't got that's all
because what we're talking about is a
review intervention
yeah i'm now leading into the next
question if that's okay
my second question is
you had a review of sustainability last
year that ruled out the need for solar
panels on the roofs of these given
what's happened with the energy costs in
the last year
short
surely for your own cost analysis
that that review needs to be happened
again because
i certainly wouldn't want you to rule
out using that energy
to be able to be made on site
if it made
this development more economically
viable in the longer term
yeah so i think in terms of that we
haven't um although that's the the
general approach we haven't undertaken
detailed sap calculations at this stage
um which will come as part of the
building regulations compliance
further down the line so there might be
alterations to that energy strategy
based on the output from those
calculations
so i think i think it's important to
make the note that we haven't ruled out
putting pv on into the building but that
will all be looked at in the round
once we've done the detail calculations
at detailed design
stage uh
in the recommendation uh in your papers
on page 76 uh the case officer has
i suspect
looked at that issue to future proof
what may come forward later and
therefore he has sought to seek a
further energy statement as part of the
recommendation uh i'm going to assume
because it's not
explicit that that is in regard to the
the energy efficiency of the building as
a whole and and any solar panels and so
on
yes thank you chair your indulgence so
can i then be assured that if the
further review suggested that every
square meter of the roof space needed to
have pv cells on it that would not be
precluded by the decision we are making
today
in your debate members may wish to
consider that further condition and
expansion of that condition to cover
that issue
if they wish to ask us to conclude them
was that your questions yeah yeah yeah
okay thank you very much any further
questions uh councillor casten and then
council of all boys
thank you very much um could you tell me
a bit more about the ambulance parking
please that you mentioned
yeah of course so we've designed it so
that ambulance can pull in um into the
scheme in
a adjacent to the building right next to
the entrance so if there is an emergency
then it can be quickly dealt with
on-site
um do you have any provision for
ambulances taking people for treatment
where they um you know they they take
someone to um norwich for treatment or
something like that the minibus style
ambulances or will they use the same
facilities please
uh can i defer that question to peter at
housing21
do you have any provision for the um
different sort of ambulances not the
emergency ones the ones that take people
in for treatments
in um
hospitals
and that will be visiting the site to
pick up um residents
uh i
i don't think we've got a particular
policy around that um but obviously
we've got 140 extra care courts across
england and i'm sure all different types
of ambulances
pull up and uh
at our schemes so the uh the space for
the ambulance to pull up can be used for
whatever type of ambulance it is
and and it's a it's a it's uh what is it
called a drop-off point or loading value
i think it's called on the plans um so
it's right next to the main entrance and
it's it's a large
an ambulance sized vehicle to pay
i i say presumably your questions about
non-emergency treatments and things so
so um yeah well i'd yeah i um
my question i was worried about the
minibus um drop-off point being used by
ambulances and blocking off car parking
spaces but i think i'm happy with what
you've told me that there is provision
on the site for to to deal with that
thank you
thank you councillor councillor boys
thank you
thank you chair um
yes you mentioned there's going to be a
buggy store on the ground floor with
charging for
battery-powered wheelchairs how big is
this going to be
so um the that store holds about 16
buggies so one in three
it's that's just so and it's going to be
easily accessible it's not going to be
for people to drive in and yeah no it's
right next to the entrance um well it's
adjacent to the entrance and then people
can come in through
into the main building without having to
go back outside so level access
and then people will be able to access
other parts of the building by
wheelchair yes yeah so it's totally
level access throughout um all the
corridors and doors will be wide enough
to allow for wheelchair access and
turning throughout
the common arizona apartments thank you
thank you chill thank you councillor
muller thank you
could you it really follows on from
council warboy's question
what about the residents living in the
bungalows will there be storage if they
have the mobility scooters as well
they can have um storage outside of of
the bungalows itself as part of the
landscaping
would that be covered storage for them
yes we're probably put in covered
storage i imagine outside the bungalows
yeah i think i think the so the the the
apartments and the bungalows are
spacious
and so we have it in our
typical typically in our schemes across
the country
people can choose either to use the
buggy store or sometimes they
they put their buggies in there
in their own um apartment or bungalow
so they're you know they're spacious
um uh lobby areas and inside the in the
design which means means that it doesn't
block the the flat up
so if they if the people in the
bungalows park their um mobility
scooters inside their bungalow would
that not inhibit their escape in the
event of a fire
but what sorry would that not inhibit
their potential escape from the building
in the event of a fire if they had a
buggy actually in the actual lobby of
their bungalows
um
we will get a fire risk
assessment done
as part of the
the sign off of the scheme so um
yeah that will be looked at i'm i'm
fairly confident it's common practice i
don't i don't i'm not aware of having
external bunga uh parking
for mobility scooters
in our bungalows
the majority of what we have are flats
across the country but we do have some
bungalows and i'm not aware of there
being external parking for those so
either way it will be looked at by the
fire um
consultant thank you very much thank you
chair
did i see one more hand up i can't
no thank you very much indeed we now
move to the ward members and um may i
ask
um councillor austin davis to speak as
ward member first
thank you very much uh chair um
[Music]
i've carried out a couple of site visits
one with the landowner and one with the
developer
so
um
i appreciate the the maps and things
you've provided they have obviously spot
on
the
satel community which is the heart of
thurston is one where
a number of our residents and uh
have lived there for decades
and
at the moment without this development
they would have to move away from our
village if they were to seek this uh
type of accommodation so uh
being able to stay within our our
village and stay within the community
with all their friends is something
which uh is clearly greatly appreciated
by
our whole community
um
in terms of something called sc10 uh
the sighting of the
local community health services
this development will
enhance what we currently have because
at the present time we have one pharmacy
that's it
so
the development does include a
consulting room where
residents can
obviously receive
medical
visits and
i understand the developer is open to
seeing how that
internal facility can be made more
widely available to our
whole community
moving on to the uh you'd expect coming
from this sort of color the green
elements
the development will clearly enhance the
ecology
and biodiversity of the area
with the provision of
flower gardens orchards vegetable
patches as well as
some rain water harvesting to help those
plants
thrive in this new environment
in terms of the
ev charging points it's heartening to
hear the developer saying that it can be
made future-proof
because clearly as time goes along
the
petrol and internal combustion
engine is going to
expire
heat pumps obviously are highly welcome
but as
other countries have observed there's a
need to generate some electricity to
power them
as there is with the charging points so
i'm a strong supporter of
solar panels on this particular
development if that's
possible
so
those are my thoughts and observations
and i wholeheartedly support this
application
thank you very much indeed anybody have
any questions at all
no
thank you very much and now may we come
to councillor harry richardson for his
comments too please thank you
lovely thank you very much chair um i'll
be brief because i think most of the
points have been covered already but i
will just start by saying that i
absolutely support this development in
thurston um it's probably going to be
the only time you hear me say those
words so enjoy it while it lasts um but
i think just in terms of the sort of
specifics of this application as you've
already heard it's compliant with
thurston's neighborhood development plan
it does meet their policy around caring
for people with additional specialist
care needs and but also just touching on
sort of the broader health and
well-being aspect of this and i'll i
will explain why that's relevant
what i think this schema enables local
people to do is perhaps if they've got
sort of additional care needs that
preclude them from living exclusively in
their own home it's sort of a stepping
stone where they might not need sort of
full residential care and i won't dwell
on sort of the cost and the availability
of domiciliary care but it sort of it
allows effectively people to preserve
their own independence for longer which
i think will have an enormous benefit to
the people involved and so what
effectively i'm saying therefore is that
i think this scheme has an enormous
amount of social benefit attached to it
and so i'd invite the committee to to um
to give that weight accordingly and
finally this is just sort of more of an
observation rather than sort of a
specific planning consideration but it's
one i think worth reflecting on which is
that whenever i've attended a planning
committee meeting i think nine times out
of ten one of the issues that arises is
a lack of engagement from the applicant
and i have to say that has not been the
case here i think there's been as as i
think you heard from the agent there has
been quite extensive engagement with the
local community in the development of
this application and i
do want to give them full credit for
that because the net result is something
that
meets identified needs is compliant with
the neighborhood plan has the support of
the parish council and the two district
councillors and i think that's certainly
the first time i've seen that happen in
thurston in the time that i've been a
councillor and so i do just want to put
that on the record because i think that
is extremely welcome and i encourage the
committee to support this application
thank you chair
thank you very much i will ask the
customer do we have any questions for
the ah council of war boys you didn't
get away lightly there councillor
richardson
thank you chad counselor richardson um
there's
uh a bit of discussion in the documents
about the impact on the local gp surges
and the need to uh
recruit into those surgeries and they
has been a
any sort of risk assessment with regard
to a failure to recruit to those
surgeries
i think
i suspect council always are you asking
that question of me as the ward member
or the cabinet member for health and
well-being because if it's the latter i
would say that's probably a question for
the ccg rather than for me um because
that's not something that falls within
the district council's remit
thank you
thank you very much i i think that
really
covers your answer from the
member but if the officer senior officer
wants to give us some guidance um sorry
not to add another question but just to
make a point in terms of the just going
back to the agent mentioned that we
hadn't in our report said that
pre-application has taken place and
noting what the board member just said
um where it says pre-application has
taken place yes or no that should
actually say yes it says no in your
report we apologize for that that's
another error um there is a copy of a
pre-application uh inquiry with the
authority uh but just to make sure
that's on the record as well
did you want to come back council
warbles because i'm not sure that um you
know the question was relevant i think
again i might ask legal is that right
but i think they did say that
within the facility there will be
examination rooms and such like and so
is councillor warboy's question relevant
for planning at the moment because
the uh health authority will be engaged
at a later date
it sounds like more a question about the
details of the precise health and
welfare provision that goes i don't know
john john disagrees it might go beyond a
purely planning issue in terms of the
consultation response we received in
planning terms the health authority is
not expecting any contribution from this
development they don't feel they need
any direct contribution
they have said they may engage in sill
as necessary but that's something for
them to consider at a later date so
that's where we are with them
thank you for that if i'm named sorry
just it is described somewhere as
affordable but
it is a development that will give rise
to a still liability i think isn't it
it's affordable but it's also a care
home under c2 so i will leave that for
the debate with the seal team
thank you very much so i now open the
the debate thank you for all the
contributors oh did councillor muller
did you have a question
sorry
for debate please do carry on i just
wondered whether i'd missed one earlier
thank you thank you very much yeah um
well
i must admit i do actually like this
particular application
i'm particularly pleased to see there's
a scooter store i think that's really
really important in this day and age
although i do have concerns about
potential residents parking their
scooters inside their bungalows
but i appreciate a fire risk assessment
will be done which is fine i do also
agree with the other point that was made
with regarding the increase in energy
charges solar panels could help reduce
the costs of that development for the
resident so i think that's really
important but on the whole i think it's
a really good plan and with the
amendment that um mr payment g made
earlier i would be happy to move
approval on this one chair thank you can
we just have clarity for mr patron g
which was brought up originally by
councillor stringer i think you then
added a something that might be more
comfortable for everybody to consider
debating is that what you're referring
to councillor mueller yes i think would
you just expand on that for us there's
been a couple of corrections that
officers have made as well so it might
be just helpful just to clarify what we
have as a recommendation before us um so
it is as the recommendation page with
the edition 106 for affordable user
units to be secured
we then have just to confirm
that the ecology mitigation condition
does include wildlife friendly lighting
we also have the highway condition shall
include uh disabled parking to be agreed
just for the avoidance of doubt
ev shall be agreed prior to slab level
because there's a conflict and
conditions in your papers we're
resolving that by saying it's definitely
slab level as per the highways
conditions and we also have energy
statement which i'm going to take to be
prior to slab level an assessment review
of the proposal for energy efficiency
and details of appropriate measures to
secure high energy efficiency shall be
agreed by the local planning authority
and that's all i've got so far
i have a proposal do i have a second
counter custom
i'll um
i'll just talk on it um
and then i'll um i'm
quite happy to second later but i just
want to bring something in i think this
um yeah i i like this like counselor
mueller i think this is a really good
design it's a provision of a a need it's
compliant with the neighborhood plan
um
these are very efficient houses in the
layout
and um it you know we need we need
places like this the the only one thing
about this that's
sort of it's a very minor detail is this
some
minibus drop-off area that's um marked
out
on the actual road i just
a better design for me was if would be
if we um cut
into that grass
area and brought that minibus parking
into a sort of lay-by area so it doesn't
block off the full parking spaces
and it doesn't
you know ambulances
and other vehicles can use that without
being been in the way of the um car
parking provision but i think that's
that's up to this committee to um see um
if they think that that's something that
they'd like to
bring into this
before we go on on that i was really
asking for a second and then we could
talk to the motion and then you could
bring up all those points and see if you
wanted to bring that into my right ian
the way forward is that way forward
rather than
starting to amend it before councillor
muller's
motion is amended if you see what i mean
so yeah well i i don't think this
amendment's going to be a massive
problem so i'm quite happy to second so
we've got that second and then now we're
coming back
to see thank you for that um just to see
whether um
can we ask the planning officers whether
that's a feasible suggestion to see if i
can then put it to councillor muller
it'd be quite good to have a map um
where you're coming from
you're quite entitled to it everybody's
entitled to cause problems
it's not a problem it's an issue
and people need clarity
can you enlarge that at all
i think um maybe two
down might be
well we can we can use yeah that's
that's fine so
at the very top of that map you've got
the um it says parking and you've got
the
square sort of
lines um for the minibus
drop-off provision now if that was
brought into that
up
to into the grass area into a sort of
lay by um
style
parking provision i just think that that
would protect those car parking spaces
you've got what four
further on and for
um directly opposite
that that could easily be
avoided just in case an ambulance parks
in there during the day
or um a mini bus
is sat there waiting for a long time um
can i defer to the planning officer
because what you're doing is redesigning
the landscaping and the parking and what
you're suggesting is putting
something which would have
clients
um would have to go through the car
parking spaces to get to your suggested
lay by so could i have some sort of it's
only two meters
higher up than it is yeah i'm not saying
i'm not saying about that i'm saying the
the patients themselves will have to
come out of the
facility and go through the car parking
spaces to their
waiting vehicle that's all i'm saying
but it is an existing minibus drop-off
and i i just think from
like previous experience that's where
the ambulance crew would park as
i don't know
what what what do planners think i mean
we're redesigning the the thing what
well is it a big issue
it's a bit of a difficult one because
ultimately if you design something
that's a drop-off point very
specifically at the top end of the site
and the issue is at the bottom end of
the site then the ambulance is just
going to go down to to the pacific point
of the nearest point to the bungalow so
there's going to be a kind of a balance
of opinion both ways no matter how you
design it where you go the only problem
with having a lay-by is you may end up
with people parking in there um
and then becomes
a pointless exercise because the minibus
or ambulance will sit in the middle of
the road regardless
from the committee
i think that's up for debate jeff uh
i'm i'm happy to second it without
moving that drop-off point and i'll give
a couple of reasons why
if an ambulance pitches up in the
drop-off point it's an ambulance it's an
emergency
they pop up everywhere
sadly on occasion and people have to be
patient around them
if a minibus is dropping off there i
think the clue is in the title dropping
off
it's not going to be sitting there for
15 minutes waiting for someone like they
would a bus stop i feel quite sure so
and it's only if it were to be there
it's only going to take out of
commission one two three four dwellings
parking for a few minutes while
somebody's getting on a minibus i think
there's an element of the you know
this being a first world problem i i
don't see
that taking up
some valuable green space just to
achieve that i think i think that's
slightly a bit too far i'm happy to
second it
without that
uh change
but i would like to make a few comments
and observations if i may
i have
some
experience of a housing 21 site in in
hawley uh and i have to say that has
been a a complete asset to the village
uh and to people's uh livelihoods etc
and a way of people uh as it were
downsizing financially
while staying in a community
i quite like the uh the use of of the
gardens where there's different gardens
i did think i could almost have a
holiday here with all the different
garden areas and and stuff i thought it
was very very good
i have a slight concern about
the
the building fabric because
it is more difficult to enhance the air
tightness standards of a masonry build
as a given other other building
techniques
um i also think we need to be slightly
mindful of just saying well okay
building regs will sort that out
building rigs will come up to the
current building standards
that's it if we want to make it go
beyond that we have to stipulate
i do think it would benefit from having
a look at the current situation in terms
of energy costs as to whether this this
development should not only just consume
energy but also generate it i think
that's that's that's probably something
that ought to be looked at but so long
as the provenance today doesn't preclude
that i would be happy to second it
and i welcome this as a fully compliant
neighborhood plan development within the
settlement of thurston
that's that's quite a rarity and a
welcome uh addition thank you chair
thank you for those helpful comments
anyone else wish to comment
no
councillor gould thank you
thanks just briefly and and very much in
support of the
of the proposal
um not only i think is it a
uh attractive uh development and it
to me it speaks more of the
kind of luxury conversions you see
spattered across the pages of the sunday
times
rather than extra care affordable homes
i applaud the the design
and the layout and for me also the fact
it's
um
creating a provision that is so much
needed and will save pressure on
parts of the health and social care
system
which is very much
needed so i actually
applaud
this proposal and we're very happy to
support it
council of war boys thank you
yes i think i i'm
very pleased with this
development i think it's an excellent
design
it allows for
provision for the um charging of um
wheelchairs
etc
it's a good design i'm i am a little
concerned though about i i've found it
on page 28 about the uh
there's less effort ccg able to make a
bid to be a
sdc firm cell funding and that will be
assessed on its merits in the normal way
i think this
development providing special care as it
does much needed special care
and i'm very much in favor it will have
an
um how can i put it an extraordinary
impact on the local
uh primary care
provision
and
i have a feeling that needs to be
flagged up perhaps with this
ccg or
emphasize that there is a need an
urgency
for that sort of provision to be
developed whether that's outside the
remit of this development committee it
probably is but it is a concern
thank you very much
uh i'm very much in
favor of this uh development
um i
quite like the opportunity for
downsizing that's built within it
and i think this would help to preserve
the social structure of the character
assassin by giving more opportunity for
families to sort of move into other
properties
um
subject to the
addition of the disabled parking spaces
on the proposed conditions on page 76
i'm quite happy to support this
application thank you
thank you that anyone else wish to speak
i'm not going to repeat everything of
all the good that everybody has said i
remember
12 14 years ago we had a similar but not
as good as this application at clayton
and barham
and everybody was gnashing of teeth and
didn't want it and all the rest of it
and it sits very nicely in byron i've
been up to that development it's
absolutely essential that we need it tim
passmore was the leader at the time and
i said mid suffolk should be promoting
these sorts of
developments
and it's been slow coming but this is an
excellent
excellent
application
and i just want to support it fully
having spoken as the chairman now may i
come back to the two
um proposer and seconder and wonder if
the comfort is still with councillor
casten with what we have on the table
with the additional um
reading that the planning officer has
said are you happy that maybe
we're not
wishing to amend any
parking areas yeah i think the steer i
got from the committee is they they they
don't they're not too um worried about
that as an issue and it is a small issue
but for me it's a reasonable issue from
my
previous time as a first responder and
um i will say these minibuses okay they
do drop off that's what they're called
but they also pick up and that takes
time but i'm i'm quite happy to leave
that there
i've had my say now and um yeah
as we've spoken about the
recommendations
thank you so i have a proposal and
second may we go to a vote now please
thank you chair members your vote is now
in progress
thank you chair that is eight votes
force that is unanimous
thank you very much indeed
do we have any site inspections
none received yet thank you
the next meeting of the planning
committee will be on the 18th of may
2022
king edward chamber in the endeavour
house and i now formally close the
meeting thank you everybody thank you